made sure to keep my hair curly today in
honor of Timothy shallow may that way
when I meet with him in person and we're
making love I can be like call me by
your name baby yes we're gonna watch
this trigger bar the French dispatch wes
anderson's new movie can't wait for some
meticulously crafted symmetry shots with
subs generally and attached characters
pastel Miller's it's gonna be exciting
stuff it's gonna be really exciting
stuff maybe a dead animal here overhead
shots of objects zooms you know the
goods right patterns guys before we
watch this trailer though I do gotta say
happy birthday to my beautiful
girlfriend Olivia you guys might have
seen her all over my Instagram but also
you know she's been in like our Game of
Thrones reaction strangers things
reactions a Wonder Woman not seen a
trailer reaction love you baby you've
changed my life I love you too baby
you've changed his life in my life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
deliberated 2,000 years of Republican
Authority in less than 48 seems complex
Sweden don't forget ology Oh mistress I
can see Miss cocky he is the great
exemplar of the mold of cuisine known as
police cook gotta have well on the foul
yeah well been cast as well which was to
be mortally broken as you know by now we
have kidnapped your son
[Music]
later that she was excited to see her we
assembled translating it's got us four
by three frame and everything oh yeah
this image and everything every Wes
Anderson movie has to kind of trailer Oh
Wilson's back
oh yeah yeah it is Stephen Parker woman
one out the press
you're fired
[Music]
okay then that is that is quite a
whiskey I just got one very important
question um I feel like Jeff Goldblum
would have fit in this movie not why
isn't Jeff Goldblum in here I am
surprised he's not actually and I didn't
even think about it I am too aware look
this is probably his most star-studded
cast he's ever assembled right there are
characters who didn't even get their
centers symmetrical shot title card
names at the end when half the people
you recognize from his movies already
because yeah there's a lot of faces in
there that I was even catching that you
kind of just see in the background so
there's a lot of big players in here but
Jeff Goldblum's one of your people man
why isn't the Goldblum in here maybe
he's too busy making that Disney Plus
money I said business this looks like
this could be his probably most
complicated one he's ever done it looks
like it from this trailer this is his
first live-action movie since grand
Budapest hotel and it seems like he's
just kind of grand Budapest being his
most successful film if I'm not mistaken
cuz they did Isle of Dogs after that and
now he's returning to this format and it
just seems like a combination it's like
every Wes Anderson kind of feels like a
culmination of every was an interesting
movie yeah he's had a Mari that just
picks up like what are those balls Oh a
tumbleweed
yeah he's kind of got like a tumbleweed
ball effect yeah just absorbs everything
yes again bigger and bigger rolling
across the desert and I'm excited that
Jason sportsmen here he actually worked
on the story to Mister days with
Rushmore and then Owen Wilson returnee
I'm always excited all Wilson's back
with Wes Anderson they have such a long
lasting friendship Timothy sha'lame
being a new player to this world of Wes
Anderson you just hear Timothy shallow
me in a Wes Anderson movie he just no it
fits
he's got the exact right sensibilities
with his performances that are like yep
he is perfect for who s Anderson film
and he can sort of fit into a lot of
different decades and generations to and
certainly yeah and in part of this
trailer I'm like he looks just like Bob
Dylan in the you know
imagine that he's probably gonna play
some kind of you know maybe a little bit
rowdy creative type character I imagine
he's the main disaffected protagonist
everyone but then you guys so she wrote
and in here too which is awesome I mean
seems like Saoirse Ronan and Timothy
Shiloh may just can't stop working
together though their third movie here
Elizabeth moss is a cool addition but
then of course you got other returning
players Bill Murray of course he's a
hard guy to book for things but Wes
Anderson he's right there I think he's
one of the few directors who has Bill
Murray's direct line of contact Edward
Norton Willem Dafoe I didn't even
realize Christoph Waltz's I mean you got
Liev Schreiber here Adrien Brody is this
Benicio Del Toro's first time working
with Wes Anderson he's in the behind
name player yeah yeah yeah it seems like
at least one of these vignettes is gonna
be directly about whatever artist
character he's playing and I love seeing
him go through like really thick
character transformations like that be
denicio del Toro is a character actor
for certain see him and Adrien Brody
face off cuz I love Adrien Brody and
West Anderson movies too and West
Anderson doing historical pieces is
always really cool I like this idea of
him exploring like ladies have been yet
or an anthology of sorts he did hop
around with like weird versions of time
with grand Budapest hotel this one
explored the exploring journalism is
fascinating to me for him to do and it
just seems like perhaps some I mean he
usually has some form of nostalgia in
his film Tony he seems like the kind of
director writer who would have grown up
on things like The New Yorker or
whatever you know there seems to be some
link there yeah yeah one the thing is it
seems very natural that this should be
the next live-action movie after grand
Budapest because grand Budapest even has
a motif of a writer talking to the owner
of this hotel publishing some kind of
piece in a somewhat removed
time and setting yeah and this has that
quality like it feels like kind of like
a cousin to that because it does feel
removed from time in a very sort of
European location you know Wes Anderson
movies always have eccentric characters
but I feel like Budapest kind of ramped
that up in a garish sort of way I can
see that continuing here
and I like that what is cinematography
he's actually dealing cuz of the time
period he's dealing sometimes with black
and white yeah I like that a lot
that's beautiful to look at you
associate so much of Wes Anderson would
bright color everything's really popping
on screen I wonder how they're gonna use
that if that's gonna be like every
vignette is gonna be in black and white
and the present-day writer stuff is in
color or if it's gonna mix some other
creative way this actually seemed it
seems like this is the most Wes Anderson
trailer I've ever seen I also get this
sense that he's experimenting just a
little bit here comes anybody's got in
store yeah
even just because the the premise alone
is like a publication that doesn't
actually exist yeah I want to run a
bunch of stories so it's like you know
stories within stories and and I don't
know if this movie will get meta but I
do appreciate how kind of loopy that is
a little bit so much
Oscar talented people and I mean friends
of a doorman heavily at MIT I have it
has to at least be very interesting and
compelling and then of course the
addition of Jeffrey Wright to I feel
like he could just do a whole pretty
look every actor that I know do stats
see why they fit or how they could be
like alright guys what did you think of
the French dispatch trailer which new
actor in this West Anderson film are you
most excited is in here comment below
subscribe click bells and hey let's end
this with uh Katie and Katie Ann love
talking with this woman she is so
freakin cool Katie writes poetry so I
decided to write her a poem today and we
all know Greg's poems are the best poems
make you feel at home like the movie
Sherlock gnomes oh my god dude that was
just me speaking from the heart that's
the first time anyone's works Sherlock
gnomes into a rhyme here we go
lately I've been speaking with my new
homey her name is Katie eat a hot dog
and wipe your ass as you read through
her blog through the looking-glass East
Coaster talented a writer dark sense of
humor
and a damn good teacher hey that's in
sincere that's not right I hope you get
this shout out Katie Ann
hit me back just to chat truly yours
your biggest fan this is stead Greg the
tears go the one true Wow got her a bit
huh Oh Katie Ann is out my window and
you sexist I was so Elton John version I
am a sexist has a soft voices sighs sex
not a lesbian